[Music]
for three billion people around the
world
seafood provides a significant source of
protein and nutrition but recent studies
show that 33% of wild fisheries are
overfished while another 60% are fished
at their maximum capacity in fact over
half the seafood we eat from thin fish
and shellfish to seaweed and algae isn't
caught in the wild it's grown through
aquaculture or aquatic farming farmed
seafood is one of the fastest growing
food industries expanding in volume by
five point eight percent each year but
different methods of aquaculture come
with different advantages and issues
some of which echo the serious problems
we've seen in industrial agriculture so
how can we avoid repeating the mistakes
we've made on land at sea
what aquaculture approaches are we
currently using and what does a
sustainable way to farm the ocean really
look like one of the most common
aquaculture methods involves large pens
made of Nets where fish are farmed
offshore in floating cages roughly a
thousand square meters in size commonly
employed off the coast of Chile and in
the fjords of Norway these fish like
many industrially farmed animals occupy
stressful overcrowded pens they produce
massive amounts of waste polluting the
surrounding areas and potentially
spreading diseases to wild species worse
still since the antibiotics employed to
fight disease aren't fully absorbed by
the fish they get excreted back into the
environment net pens are also
susceptible to escapes unleashing huge
numbers of fish which compete for
resources and weaken the local gene pool
with genes adapted for captivity escaped
fish can even disrupt local ecosystems
as invasive species other techniques
such as manmade coastal ponds commonly
used for shrimp farming in Southeast
Asia create additional environmental
problems just like net pens these ponds
are prone to spreading pollution and
disease their construction also
frequently destroys important ecosystems
like mangroves and marshes which protect
coastal areas from storms provide
habitats and absorb tons of greenhouse
gases one way to solve these problems is
to farm fish on land and completely
contains
tanks and raceways can recirculate and
filter water to prevent pollution but
even fully contained facilities still
contend with another major hurdle fish
meal about 10 percent of the seafood
caught globally is used to feed animals
including carnivorous farmed fish
researchers are working on fish feed
made of insects and plant-based proteins
but for now many inland fish farms are
connected to overfishing all these
obstacles can make sustainable
aquaculture feel a long way off but
innovative farmers are finding new ways
to responsibly farm the Seas the most
promising solution of all may be to look
lower on the food chain instead of
cramming large carnivorous fish into
pens we can work with natural ocean
systems to produce huge amounts of
shellfish and seaweeds these low
maintenance flora and fauna don't need
to be fed at all in fact they naturally
improve water quality filtering it as
they feed off of sunlight and nutrients
in the seawater by absorbing carbon
through photosynthesis these farms help
battle climate change and reduce local
ocean acidification while creating
habitats for other species to thrive
shifting to restorative ocean farming
could provide good jobs for coastal
communities and support healthy plant
and shellfish based diets that have an
incredibly low carbon footprint in just
five months four thousand square meters
of ocean can produce 25 tons of seaweed
and 250,000 shellfish with the right
distribution network a series of small
farms collectively the size of
Washington State could feed the planet
farms like these are already popping up
around the globe and a new generation of
farmers is stepping up to pursue a more
sustainable future done properly
regenerative ocean farming could play a
vital role in helping our oceans our
climate and ourselves
if overfishing continues at its current
rate will the ocean ever run out of fish
check out this video to learn more
[Music]